we flew him all the way from Georgia to
Calabasas he is a official thick boy of
the UFC heavyweight division it's Chris
Barnett AKA Beast Boy on this week's
food truck Diaries and I'm feeding them
fish let's go
[Music]
[Music]
I need everything I get super thick boy
[Music]
and I like Beast Boy what's up big dog
appreciate you having me sir dude I
wanted you on here the minute you won
that fight when you did that big thick
boy and people were tagging us being
like you guys need to sponsor them the
first thick boy athlete that's it we
need that front flip I was like I hit my
I might get a hold of him right now
right this second you blew up man I
appreciate it you blew up dude and then
I think uh part of the viewer come up
your success too is you're an authentic
dude and you just like to have fun and
right now Society needs a little more of
that like you don't take anything too
serious and then what I really loved is
obviously you're a good athlete because
you're in the freaking UFC but you dude
your footwork Daddy's football
dance bro like legit dance huh that's it
that's it man you got to think like uh
lomachico's Dad wouldn't let him start
boxing until he learned how to dance
actually so yeah so yeah man like that
that's always been my uh my come up
actually my my story that's how I got
into MMA was uh I'm dancing from I was
actually in a club in Tampa dancing
Peabody shout out peabodies uh we was in
there dancing getting out ah break that
you're doing all your b-boys everything
everything and then shut down you gotta
think we're in a club in Tampa so these
dudes roll up
so you got some fight moves huh and I
was like hey all right hang on this is
going to win one or two ways I know
you're like a ninth degree black girl
they just they just saw the Belly Up
There moving on the floor that was it
they probably saw like you know like it
was it was it was like a little
something when I popped and I did like a
little kick and he was like that guy
knows martial arts so he ran up on me
had these little flyers and was like uh
hey I see you know a little bit of
martial arts whoa whoa whoa whoa wait
yeah I just want to hand you this
tomorrow we're gonna have a tryout show
up and I was like I'm at least
10 shots in like this we're done we're
done this what dance moves he saw
probably was a bunch of
drunken Kung Fu that's probably what he
saw he probably saw some jungle Kung Fu
but uh he saw something he saw something
and it was MMA tryouts like it was MMA
trials for um what was the company xfc
at the time it was called xfc and uh
they were based out of Tampa they
they were known for kind of having Not
freak shows but I don't remember Dan
McGee or Dan McGee the big tall he
fought Jonathan Ivy who was like my
height yeah so they had those kind of
fights going on you know what I mean uh
so they brought me out I was actually
supposed to fight uh Imani Lee he passed
away uh he was a K1 fighter Big K1 okay
uh he was about three something at the
time I was 3 40 3 20. so yeah
yeah so uh they brought me into the gym
and uh actually go back to the tryouts
we're all out there doing the tryouts
hundreds of people we're talking at
least solid 80.
everybody want to be a fighter this time
too this is when kimbo's probably
kimbo's like second fight on the
internet one where he's at the boat yard
that one there so everybody in their
mama wanted to be a fighter at the time
uh we're all out there doing these
drills and stuff now I told you we were
in the club I left the club at four
o'clock tryouts were at six
awesome
yeah dude like if you want to be a
fighter
so I show up two of the coaches like
were doing drills he goes
somebody been drinking and I was like
yeah that guy him him over there it's me
I was hammered two hours ago I wanted to
with the look that this guy had no key
Lee what's his name the look he was
given was like this is unacceptable yeah
I got saved by this little dude he was
like I think a 135 or he out of nowhere
it was just like
and I was like yeah he's definitely been
drinking something out of here I'm here
first he's got to go this is too serious
to me taking it that way yeah but yeah
luckily something shouts are you
sparring just hitting mids rolling
grappling again I got a Taekwondo in
wrestling background right so they
wanted us to hit Mitch never box before
in my life they wanted us to do Jiu
Jitsu I knew how to wrestle yeah every
one of my Jujitsu matches ended up with
me in the pen like yep what did I win
they're like no you got to submit them I
was like okay let me pin them again did
I win no they're home no you didn't but
uh damn it luckily enough we got to the
stand-up rounds I ended up doing uh
spending sidekick that shut the whole
competition now they were just like what
what you're not gonna see a big
dude that was beautiful I had set it up
almost the same way the little step
turned yeah right there Brandon but he
went and fell or whatever shout out to
Paul still friends with him now today
we'll kick the [ __ ] Orlando Paul
taking this away for me but uh but yeah
I ended up if you look on paper now I
want it I didn't win it that day a guy
named Julio Gallegos actually won the uh
won the tournament he actually went on
and was actually decent uh successful I
think he went about seven and three and
then life happened but uh but yeah man
that was my uh introduction into yeah
man yeah it's a hell of an intro and how
old are you at that time I was 20 what
are we we've been in this game
15 so I was like 24.
yeah 24. yeah yeah or whatever just
literally out drinking time that was it
it was Florida there was something to do
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
Saturday Sunday of course Monday just
repeat dude
yeah oh
great comment too but what's weird about
that is you never prior to that you
never thought about competing next month
because if you look at your background
you have you know again your family owns
a Taekwondo school your dad's black belt
your mom's black belt your brothers
that was part of the reason why I didn't
pursue the fighting aspect of it because
my brother was he was doing it he was
just like I said I'll find my lane
somewhere else that's one reason why I
started wrestling was just because
something different something different
you know I mean this Taekwondo was he
was taller than me his kicks looked
better than mine and some I'm not sure
highlights just wheel kicking his poor
basic white dudes with headgear on just
like God that was it man so he he
literally he had everything and I was
just like yeah do my own thing man I'll
figure out something you know but uh
yeah dude like it was it was fighting
would have been
like if I had 10 things it would have
been number 10. like you know I mean on
the list it was the original goal
life to be honest with you at that time
I'll say in my life was where we
partying the next day yeah
just a when's the next party that was
that was my my goal Dance Floor School
uh we'll get in there you know whatever
type thing but uh but yeah at that time
man I would have never I would I knew I
wanted to do something
around people like I like I'm just gonna
sound weird but I didn't mind like
retail jobs I like going up to people
and being like hey how can I help you
yeah you know I mean I didn't mind that
dude because you're in good
conversationalist and also you have like
a positive energy so you kicked ass
yeah like every every store manager I've
ever had Calabasas let's see how this
fight look now we come out and start
selling these houses
but when I see you when I saw your
footwork I'm like yes I have a football
background yeah I mean I mean you were
born in Spain but your dad's in the
military in the Air Force and then you
came over to George when you're five so
to me I was like Georgia heavy football
literally I figured looking at your
footwork I'm like you had to play D
tackle or something coming up that's it
that's it I liked it for the frustration
aspect like I was playing D tackle yeah
you mean to tell me I got my older
brother picking on me and I can go out
there to my little Peewee leagues and
flatten these dudes out you know what
I'm saying so uh yeah football was it
was always there always gifted athlete
all that you know type of jazz but it
just wasn't but I had a high school
coach yeah he called me out he goes why
don't you compete the way you know you
can and I was just like
okay I'm Sorry You Gotta Dance Floor out
here though God damn it but that was one
thing too though he was he was smart
with his incentives he was like you got
to think you get a sack you can get up
you can do the Reggie right oh yeah that
was like Junior sale oh yeah just get a
sack you can [ __ ] dance tonight
they're gonna cheer for you and that
whole aspect of it hearing that the
crowd I will say if I took anything from
football it was that that love that you
can get how quick that could turn on you
too but
if you didn't have that great comeback
like you got your ass whooped dude I
wouldn't be here yeah
not to say it like that but people like
winners like you know I mean it is like
winners but people like people who are
authentic that's true I think that comes
across you know like you were so happy
and you're when uh who was at DC you
went on the mic yeah like you're so
happy and just like grateful to be there
and you're really like uh humble too you
know what I'm saying like you weren't
like anybody can get these hands like
everyone's like whoa dude I'm going to
kill everybody
I want Francis oh whoa bro chill yeah
Jon Jones
Chill dude but yeah I think that comes
off so people Vibe with that you know
and then when you go to your social
media you're dancing and doing the damn
thing yeah you got to man no no I try to
be as transparent as as possible you
know what I'm saying but uh like it's
it's it's a whirlwind just to because I
could I couldn't tell you right now what
I said after that fight that was all
almost from here yeah dude like I
couldn't tell you all I remember saying
UFC apparently yeah
what the [ __ ] just happened I missed out
on two sponsors apparently because I
didn't say what yeah what I was supposed
to say to bring up their name it's like
bro it's really good sorry I just got
push in my head 13 times you want me to
remember here uh thinking of it now I
can't think of it but uh but yeah dude
like there's there's a deeper passion
now like to get get the
the notes and stuff actually like this
morning just going through Instagram hey
man I just want to let you know you
always have a house here in Scotland I
didn't know what I wanted to do with
myself I saw you you just made me smile
yeah I made it through my day and I was
like yeah it's dope you right there man
right there I'm never coming today man
I'm actually never gonna be in Scotland
but never gonna meet you but
yeah we can link up but yeah dude like
just the
the passion that's poured back into me
from it now like you get the you know
every every here and there now every you
know the the cool little stories or
whatever but now it's it's every day
I've got motivation like I literally if
I ever get in one of those reps hang on
100 go to yourself all right let me get
up this dude right here ain't got no
legs and he don't walk to the store you
know what I mean type thing so it's just
like he's got doing wheel kicks with no
legs there it is there it is so I have
no excuse you know what I mean yeah and
it's your family because coming from
such a thick Taekwondo background and
they have their own school out there in
Georgia I'm sure they're proud of you
right oh yeah like and it's it's my I'll
never get it from my mom and and Dad as
far as
there's always something more I could do
but I love it like they know they know I
need that type of it's never like a
where you didn't land it you didn't do a
540 it's like no it's like well hey next
time step back then throw it and then
it's like oh I didn't think about it
it's always your mom it's next time
let's not start the first round like
that there you go you're like that's
fair mom my mom won't even watch my
fights after because she goes all your
first rounds you get beat up I can't do
it no more and I was like but you always
come back she was like yeah yeah but
that first round I swear Chris if I was
there I throw a knife or something I'm
like all right guys
I'll become a faster starter Mama yeah
having my pops in the corner
um yeah he was uh during a lot of the uh
when I was over in Asia during that run
he was in the corner a lot and that
right there that helped like that
centered me you know what I mean just
because I'll have that that familiar
voice that's since you've been a kid
that that that type A mentality too like
you have to I have to make sure I I
please you know can't let pop stuff
exactly that's the main thing you know
what I mean but uh but yeah now then my
brother he he didn't make it no better
he'll throw in his well look tell you
what you lost a little weight you'd be
able to do 720 off and it's like no
everybody can beat you
what's his name uh Curtis okay
let me have my moment man between them
like they're it's always
it's always brought with jokes though
behind it you know I mean there's of
course we have the serious moments but
it's always like kind of love yeah you
could be doing it this way yeah we see
you yeah well you know you know type
that but uh but yeah no man always big
support and big love you know from from
them it makes sense yeah otherwise you
wouldn't be such a loving guy if you
can't exactly be a dark person make a
few shows on this one I'm like I'm gonna
skip the family talk yeah you look into
it like holy [ __ ] what happened yeah
they started talking about their mom
like hey you want some chicken
your dad that's terrible hey uh you know
let's say [ __ ] sake but um I think too
what's interesting about your story it's
not like you're this like three fight
young bushy-eyed fighter like you got
some fights yeah well I got my scars
yeah looking into into your career like
after I I was a I'll be completely
transparent I was a fan after the Jake
fight I'm like oh this dude's [ __ ]
great you're dancing coming out
I'm texting these guys are a big sick
boy group chat I'm like this needs to be
the first thick boy sponsored athlete
blah blah and then
um I didn't look at your record and I
saw uh your first fight they gave you
Ben Rothwell yeah
on the phone eight days notice
trust me that dude his heart I thought
right yeah
a little spitting back elbow Johnstown
not a big deal now I got overzealous and
rushed and he clipped me let's take a
little break from chatting with my
fellow thick boy Chris Barnett aka the
Beast Boy cause season
is here for the NFL it's week three kids
my Denver Broncos aren't looking so hot
but I'm still going to place some money
on them and I only place bets on my
friends at DraftKings and that's right
the NFL action is full swing at
DraftKings all right an official sports
betting part of the NFL we talking
touchdowns big plays even bigger wins
new customers can bet just five dollars
on any NFL team and win 200 dollars and
free bets if they do that's not enough
say less everyone can boost their
winnings with DraftKings stepped up same
game parlays right now for every leg you
add can boost your winnings up to 100
100 with pallets bigger than ever why
bet on football anywhere else not using
DraftKings you ain't doing it right man
to make things even sweeter you can
throw down on stepped up same game
parlays once per game all freaking
season long download DraftKings
Sportsbook app right now use promo code
shop show Schaub to get 200 in free bets
if your team wins when you place a Five
Dollar Bet on any football game that's
code shop show Schaub show only at
draftking Sportsbook an official
Sportsman part of the NFL minimum age
eligibility restrictions apply see show
notes for details now let's get back to
the freaking program when I saw your
first fight to get in the FC with Ben
roethl I'm like why the [ __ ] would they
do that and then I look and I'm like
well it got you into the UFC you gotta
go through some [ __ ] so if Ben Rothwell
is your ticket in who gives us not to
say I took it as that I was like four
ounce gloves anybody's got to say yes
you know anybody that that was the whole
thing and then I realized
that Vegas
elevation is is not crazy but on eight
days notice yeah
second round I was looking at my corner
hey man y'all got y'all got some oxygen
for sale does anybody have any oxygenes
when you're one minute in the second
round coach goes hey shut up four
minutes left though what the [ __ ] are
you doing tell me when there's a minute
left why would you say four minutes
are you going off third timer
is it four though
um it's a nightmare but I I and tell me
if I'm off on this when I watch uh some
of your other fights uh like when you uh
spinning heel kicked homeboy
um who used to find that middleweight
and then this last fight when I watch
those fights because the Volante fight
was in Mass Square Garden yeah right yes
I watched all your fight three came on
and the energy and the the kind of the
fun you're having in your wins you can
tell the Rothwell fight you weren't
having fun
you came out like and you can't even see
your face I don't know if you've watched
it again
just like this dead man walking
terrified yeah one I didn't want to
quote unquote because
Danny didn't make it no better he just
dropped the video this is a guy to watch
out for and I was like man y'all eight
days notice
watch out if you give me three months to
prepare
eight days ago
everybody dude and beat most everybody
like he's a Savage that's a thing like
he's beat Alice had brought me out for
that for that Travis Brown like he's a
he's a [ __ ] sound dude he must than
that uppercut he caught me with one I
think in the first round and I was just
like this is dumb why am I doing this
this is why we why are we here right now
the the difference I'll say fighting in
that Apex and then fighting in the MSG
or fighting in the T-Mobile Arena I'm a
crowd person I'm an energy yeah you know
why because you're a performer that's
exactly exactly the certain guys that
need that like Conor McGregor if you put
them in the Apex sign it's fun you put
them in front of you know T-Mobile
master Square Garden he's going to show
up I have to you you got to yeah it's
like it's the I feel it like I don't
know like the the Jake fight that second
round when they were born that Barn that
I was like so this is what Rocky felt
like oh my God I gotta do it
in real life I feel like some WWE stuff
because I was I was down I was down and
out quote unquote you know what I mean
yeah and then here we go with the
yeah
for real man but uh but yeah the the
energy like just when I was walking out
this last time and the crowd was like
because at MSG they were kind of off to
the side they were right there yeah so I
was like oh my God I can feel the people
like you know I mean I can feel they're
yelling at me it's like don't spill beer
on me right now but like you know I mean
but like it it was
oh we like I couldn't I couldn't even
describe like just coming out you know I
had a couple of things I wanted to
actually do but they were right there
and I was just like well never mind
forget what I wanted to do y'all are
y'all are feeding me right now they came
natural vibed off at dancing it's
beautiful that Square Garden too you
started dancing like oh man I had to
Harlem Shake yes in in New York you got
to do it yeah you got to do it you know
what I mean but uh I do like to do that
too like Vegas they don't have no big
artists or whatever so I was like ah
we'll take a Georgia with them a little
swag so you know get them get them there
but uh you need something no well now
the people have expectations yeah
exactly I bet you're on the main card
next
that's what's up yeah man I mean hey you
know I'm not gonna say no yeah
so for you too is your was your family
because you've had a lot of fights
before you got the UFC with your family
like hey uh you uh you're what about the
UFC like when's that coming my pops was
because he's been a fan since the horse
racing days or whatever he's always uh
because of course football once I hit
about what that sophomore year and I was
still the same height he was like so hey
how about wrestling huh you ever think
about wrestling you know you got to take
my nose you're like no
I'm starting detailing I know I know
there's nobody in the NFL
I was good five eight on a good day five
nine if you ask the UFC yeah yeah but
like there's no five seven starting
details no no no no no no not at all big
dude big big old boy man like and it was
crazy because my
junior year yeah my junior year actually
got a chance to talk to Mark Rick who
was the UGA football coach at the time
oh [ __ ] and uh he just told me straight
up he goes hey Barnett I know low man
wins but I need you a little bit tall
and I was like do you not realize what
you just said I physically can't
shout out here football dreams and he's
like yeah that was part of it that was
part of the reason why that's probably
not until now [ __ ]
this Juco you speak of what is that
let's go where are they based off he's
like oh it's all over man yeah you'll
fit in better then tell me but yeah man
like uh it it just
him between him is telling me that and
then my pops being like
hey you know
I get it you good but you're not tall
and yeah always kind of threw me off
because the low man wins right yeah yeah
I get it I get it and I was one of them
like when they did put me on the line I
hated being on offense so much that I
would just I would just be dirty like
I'd get underneath the shoulder present
but I don't want to be here right now or
something no problem yeah you'd be a
problem with yourself I could I could
move like a whole like yeah I bet
D1 four five star whatever blah blah
blah they put me out either at Center
which I hated our guard man linebacker
if you don't get your little butt out of
here it's not like a security guard yeah
damn near you know what I'm talking to
somebody at the club after that there
was a couple of uh a couple of plays
where they let me pull back man okay
Chris you gotta hit a gap which one is
that I didn't know what I was doing but
like just running straight right that's
about right they said think of you when
you were little and run the ball I said
enough said that a couple touchdowns
some poor linebackers like what in the
[ __ ] what is that
it was I had everything they quote
unquote needed except for what's weird
is you don't look like if if someone
naked eye I would say
265 really I'm like 280 right now
yeah yeah
I mean you must wait the last time
and heavyweight man that's right so in
regards to making weight uh obviously
you have to cut the 265 how big of a
issue is that for you is it pretty easy
yeah like literally that was one of the
reasons why the UFC didn't sign me at
first because I was 320. I never liked
cut ain't no way you're gonna make the
cut you know I mean so I made it a
couple of times earlier in the career
and then honestly that Japan thing came
around and they were like we want you as
big as possible if you can still do the
stuff you do I said say less yeah I
think I was like 350 when I fought
Trevor's view yeah man like you can you
can just view uh second round TKO he
actually he took him no we we had on
shoes I shouldn't have worn the shoes I
had the shoes on so I was like I can't
kick wait too much Chris yes I can no
like oh because eventually yeah mentally
I was like okay we're boxing and
wrestling like I had it set in my head
there but literally he had his wrestling
shoes on and kicked the house
oh we keep doing shoes okay that's
literally where I went you know but uh
you did a nice little thing uh dump in
the beginning and uh I tried to roll it
at the end now he's a wrestler wrestler
he sat back on me five thousand times
yeah man but uh then second round I knew
he was going to try to like he would
rush and then try to get the grip so he
came in I just said step back should I
cook
but uh but yeah that Japan wave for a
hot minute it it was fun super unhealthy
though Japan like some big do like they
want a freak Show when I show up hey
we're gonna go to the sushi place we're
gonna film you eating as many pieces of
sushi that's all you can the fight's
tomorrow they're like yeah and literally
I fly in on Wednesday or fly out Tuesday
get there basically Thursday fights
Friday leave Saturday you know what I
mean they're talking about as soon as I
land all right we got a sushi place set
up we got some ill we want you to try
something horse meat too I was like
okay I guess you know what I mean but
fill you up on shark fin soup that is
delicious
I knew they gave you that [ __ ] I knew it
snorting right now
people want to rag Alistair for the
horse meat
I'm not gonna lie to you it's nice man
it's it's
I guess because it's different and and I
don't know just the way they the way
they cooked it too that might have had
something to do with it but
it was threw me off at first when I
first heard on him sometimes I take the
horse meat and I mix it in I don't and
then I was like in America like Ugh
disgusting
It's My Little Pony it's good My Little
Pony was banging I ain't gonna lie to
you
but the horse meat was legit dude it was
it was it was it was A1 it was A1 threw
me off I'm not gonna lie to you but you
don't have to because you just got done
fighting so you have everything coming
up no no no yeah all right nobody goes
on [ __ ] shops show that [ __ ] dummy
he can't have it no food barnetness
weight again
he sabotaging my business on purpose
well let me feed your man
back to this
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
you want me to go first yeah yeah yeah
I'll do the mahi-mahi
with the uh the rice and the coleslaw
and then I'll also do another one of the
sirahi tuna
yep with the rice and coleslaw y'all got
the vegan fish
and uh no okay no I'm joking now let me
get the shrimp a little vegan option
please
[Laughter]
uh yeah I guess yeah the shrimp lovers
uh the rice and coleslaw yeah I got
almonds in your coleslaw
okay that'd be nice it's different yeah
you guys got good good slaw in Georgia I
like a good slaw in the summertime
sweet tea
beans on the side yeah [ __ ] your pants
all day I think that's it man that's all
you want yeah
yeah that's it brother
[Music]
last break I swear I know you guys are
chomping at the bit to hear my boy Chris
Barnett chat about his upbringing chat
about the fights chat about his mama
chat about his kids I love him too but
before we get back to it a lot of y'all
out there asking about Kratom you're
like when can I try Kratom where do I
get it what's the best how do you take
it well here's my little secret I use
only one Kratom that I trust because
Graham's the wild west right now
remember CBD like five years ago you're
like I guess this is safer should I use
this and I'm telling you with happy
hippo Kratom you can trust him I take it
they have a shot they have a pink
lemonade shot I take that right before
any show I do I'll take it before I go
on stage they have pills they have
gummies they have all in all sorts of
different ways you can take Kratom it's
delicious and also it's only one
ingredient you're talking about Kratom
pure Kratom don't leave it up to
guesswork don't just trust the internet
trust your thick friend here because
I've been using Kratom for a hot second
and it's the only Kratom I trust these
days all you got to do if you're
interested in trying some Kratom visit
happyhippo herbals.com use promo code
thick boy you get 20 off for Life use
them as many times you want your mom
your dad your aunt your gay brother
whoever it is they get 20 off for Life
use that code as many times as you want
again that's Happy Hippo herbals.com
promo code thick boy 20 off for life
you're welcome all right fam Last Read I
promise for reals Last Read because this
is gonna help you guys out for all you
out there that you've been in that flow
State you're working on a project and
you're like man I'm cranking this thing
out what's going on that's what the
experts the scientists talk about being
in the flow state that Zen State and
you're like how do I get back there how
what do I meditate do I need to hire an
expert you don't what if I told you it's
a little pill called Alpha Brain from my
friend that on it what I do is I take
two little pills and it gets me into
that flow state so I'm just chatting to
this camera by myself right now so I'm
in the Flow State Daddy I can get there
whenever I want whether I'm on stage
doing stand-up I'm doing podcasts I'm at
a freaking family reunion barbecue I
don't want to be out but your boy is
dropping gems on the family because I'm
in the Flow State because the Alpha
Brain it got me there you're talking
about nootropic one million bottles sold
over 1 million you guys know by now
Alpha Brain Joe Rogan swears by it says
it helps inform better sentences you
think that guy knows a thing or two
about talking yeah be more like Joe
Rogan all right Joe Rogan for president
there I said it not a big deal if you
want to try the best nootropic in the
world and it's safe and it's also from a
brand you can trust go to onnit.com FTD
and you get 10 off 10 off Alpha Brain
and here's what's cool you're like man
I'm thinking about trying it if you
don't like it you get your money back
you get your money back that's how
confident we are You're Gonna Love Alpha
Brain that on it so go to onnit.com FTD
that gives you 10 off all right or you
can go to your local Walmart and pick it
up that's boring let's go into Walmart
not me I'd rather have it delivered to
my house and also save ten percent by
using your boys promo code on it.com
slash FTD now let's get back to the
program you I feel man I keep you think
I'll be doing the show long and I've
what four years now you think I know how
to order man right just always gets
better your food looks so much better
man it's just that shrimp taco that's
what I'm really I know he [ __ ] up
there's no cocktail sauce you like
cocktail sauce a little horseradish yeah
that would have been yeah I've been
ideal
your ass would be nice if they took the
tails off the shrimp that you know
there have been times to where I've had
a couple and the Tails have gone down
with it I know my my throat is probably
just all scarred up and everything but I
was just like you know what
Tail's a tail at the end of the day
now I know you got some good food in
Georgia you got some good spots out
there yeah man what are we talking about
oh there's a barbecue spot downtown uh I
think it's just called like UGA barbecue
um ran by just old southern black dude
you can tell he he's probably I mean he
might have changed the Fish Grease once
in the past 20 years
he uses cast iron like in everything man
uh is it a popular spot where you gotta
wait yeah dude like what's today
uh
1995 it's a day
coming up just [ __ ] CT flares up oh
man like he
he I don't know you can tell
there's love put into it man and then
like on the same day oh my God I can
imagine game day like the Georgia
Bulldog game day wrapped around around
and then he's downtown like he's in a
perfect location I'll say like when
we're out late he's perfect game day is
the worst because you don't you you're
you if you don't if you're not the first
like 20 to get there you you're gonna be
there for at least an hour you're not
getting any tri-tip that's the first
thing you know the burnt ends that's my
favorite yeah man like and then he makes
everything fresh even though did you
make his own sausage yeah he like I've
only seen him when he's not there I've
seen them kind of not cheat or whatever
but it just gets so busy he can't go
back there and you know do it all then
there's another so he's using
Masterpiece [ __ ] yo hey you can tell
the difference you can tell the
difference like honestly on a Wednesday
from a Saturday you can tell the
difference of what he's actually doing
because he's a small mom and pop exactly
he's normally back there whipping it up
himself and on Saturday he brings in
some other folks you know what we got to
do my brother cousins you know what we
gotta do since you're so awesome and I
feel like we're friends now but um I
feel like we need to take the crew and
go down there and go that barbecue spot
that's the next should be at that
barbecue spot
after you start some dude with a
spinning wheel kick over there I'm gonna
call him back hey there are you going
back to George I'm like yep the crew's
flying down let's go that's what we're
going to do let's go let's meet though
that one I don't know if it means this
many dudes but it'll be a fun time
so you have the good barbecue space and
I know your mom can cook right now man
like that that was that's part of the
reason why I was
343 whatever like I didn't want to lose
to that right I'd come over to the house
I didn't have to worry about cooking and
like it got to the point to where
the grocery store was my mom's house I
just pull up and be like hey yo what'd
you make today okay let me get about
eight of those six of these and then
she'd make so much
portion wise
in my head the way I Justified it was
Mom I'm not gonna let you waste this
phone no I'm not gonna let you waste
with an effort I gotta eat it your mom's
like that nine thousand dollars bro and
guess what all of it went down well yeah
yeah
that was amazing does your mom have like
a special dish uh salmon your mom
specializes that's what I'm saying this
Sunday that's why I didn't get it I saw
it on the truck I was like yeah
Mama's cooking salmon on Sunday I better
not yeah I do like on Sunday she'll
she'll throw down with like honestly
typical chicken uh fish stuff like that
but when it comes to Salmon I don't know
what she does she puts like a rub on it
I don't know what it is and she won't
let me know either and like kitchen wise
you try to sneak in there so it's a
secret recipe a fork a knife Something's
Gonna Come at you so you're just like
I'll wait I like this food too much
secret recipe before before anything and
your kids eat eat all that they grub
eating that too I got lucky I'll say
because when my kids were like vegetable
kids first before like they wouldn't
yeah
that's what are your feelings a little
bit Yeah I was so hurt yeah right here
right here
oh man this is chicken yeah no put that
green bean down eat this chicken man
like more broccoli yeah
when you're here now the who watches the
kiddos grab my grandpa oh yeah my mom
they live close yeah yeah they're like
literally I'm
seven I'm eight minutes my house is
eight minutes from my mom's house so it
just it works beautifully like with
China and everything and then but my
kids schedule is
damn near like as hectic as mine oh my
kids are busy and I am dude like between
the soccer and the Taekwondo and my son
said talk to my assistant the other day
yeah I was like what what again same as
my family what brought us together was
Taekwondo yep it's the same it's like
it's repeating it's repeating all the
time yeah like that's when we can get in
there and I can hey man that kid didn't
look too oh Dad yeah you know so like
that's when we're actually quote unquote
families when we're being active because
your home base yeah like dinner you know
it's what are we in 2022 I don't know
too many families that eat at the table
anymore yeah you got YouTube and
everything else and it's tough that's
literally my son who he'll make it about
five minutes
okay so uh YouTube is uh all right eat
real quick yeah like there's no way you
ate all that broccoli yeah buffalo
cheese
there's no way but I could be FaceTiming
his buddies and [ __ ] I'm like no see
we're I'm not there yet my daughter just
asked me for a phone and I was like oh
no they don't get a phone yeah man this
is my iPad
they've got all the
tablets and all that jazz and then it's
tough to avoid it you know because that
it is a good tool too because they learn
a lot of [ __ ] from it and it's also prop
is so addictive they keep up with the
family on it all yeah exactly but my kid
like someone I'll take them Jiu Jitsu or
about to dinner and someone you know ask
me for a picture talk to you about
something am I suddenly go Dad is that
your follower really loudly
don't come up Don't Call Him a follower
right that hurts his feelings man don't
call people oh no and he ain't wrong
when he write though
I mean technically he follows me on
social you know what man it's not cool
just pipe down dude oh man and then you
I know this might be a touchy subject so
we don't have to cover this at all man
but uh I know even going that this fight
meant a lot too because also your your
fiance passed away yeah well you know
what's crazy again if it's not something
you want to talk I ain't a journalist
good no no no uh what's crazy is
so that last Camp right all that was
going on I was maybe getting an hour of
training a day you know what I mean
going into fighting yeah buddy like wow
because we were in the hospital
what
from February 8th she had uh she had a
seizure randomly
um so from February 8th until May 10th
we were in the hospital like I would I
would go in
was it say 6 A.M
I'd maybe get the train at 12 like Scott
would come down and you know get some
like pad work I don't need this is we're
in the UFC you know what I mean like so
LA Fitness exactly you know what I mean
like so I'm barely getting those and
then trying to
deal with that and explain to the kids
that was the part that really made it
I'll say super super tough because is uh
was your fiance their mom yeah yeah that
was yeah that was their bomb you know
what I mean so they're constantly asking
Hey where's Mommy Hey where's Mommy
Hazel like all through February about
March I was kind of like you know the
doctor's giving me signs of hope so I'm
like I'm sorry uh just to backtrack
there
um she had a seizure and I just you guys
didn't think of things you have cancer
no okay so her mom had Ms uh multiple
sclerosis cirrhosis and what she ended
up initially having is called
Encephalitis which is a swelling of the
brain the water yeah yeah swelling of
the brain and then it kind of falls
under the umbrella of
um uh Ms oh wow you know what I mean how
old was she she just turned 30. yeah
dude you know what I mean like I'll take
that back we'll be 30 would have been 30
this October this was 29th yeah yeah you
know what I mean so there was no signs
or nothing just zero to a hundred
literally she well if you ever there's a
movie called brain on fire with with uh
the girl from kick ass
um I know you're talking about her she's
great she's uh she she plays a role
perfect everything that happened in that
movie literally happened to me like uh
well not me but like to her yes
um but like just the so she she was
having a random pain in her neck which
of course in the movie they were talking
about uh uh like random pain yeah just
like random random neck pain so I was
getting her all type of massages and
like we I have 13 massage machines in my
house now you know what I mean uh and it
wouldn't go away so she went and got
these um muscle relaxers called
something the doctor was like hey this
is all you need help now he even warned
it though he said these are strong they
could make you have a seizure oh wow so
we're loud okay cool whatever we'll do
what we're supposed to do take it water
bed yeah
February 8th 2 34 I wake up just to go
pee she season and I'm like
oh the doctor wasn't lying like you know
whatever I go over there I'm I'm trying
to get everybody
yeah I've dealt with a seizure one time
when I was eight years old and this dude
that's not funny but this guy took a
spoon and was trying to get him from
like he's like I can't let him eat his
tongue type thing we were like yeah I'm
like what the [ __ ] it's kind of stop
yeah dude you know what I'm saying so
seizures are scared you're my son had
seizures
that was that's one thing that I was
worried about with the kids too because
my son had one when he was two years old
yeah and we didn't know if this whole Ms
thing is uh like yeah hereditary or
related but we can't technically get
them tested until they're of age you
know what I mean to hormones and stuff
stop dropping so she has that seizure
and then what happens after that she has
a seizure
they say it's the medicine it's in their
home they send her home uh uh she has
another seizure she we leave the
hospital at 6 00 a.m and this goofy girl
wants to go to work she just had a
seizure but that was her mind like she
was she was that type she was like I got
a bus for the family type you know I
mean so she goes to work she has another
seizure at work she calls me she's like
yo I think I hit my head before I fell I
kind of remember falling I'm like why'd
you go to work like like I had the
chance to go to the gym uh that morning
I was like why are you at work and
actually they were filming uh UFC uh I
never apologized to Raven uh they were
filming at the time and I was like yo yo
she had a seizure we might have to dial
back on the filming or whatever and uh
she has that second one
send her to the hospital again they're
like it's got to be the medicine you
know blah blah blah Cinder home again
what no one did any of the testing
nothing is correct we didn't get a CT
scan until like the third time so she
has a third seizure
we finally get oh I get to the point
where like we're not leaving until we
get done this isn't normal Something's
Gotta you know give she's popping back
out of these like
what what is wrong yeah she's fine yeah
I'm like you were just Harlem shaking
for like 30 minutes what do you mean
what's wrong with me you know what I
mean so she uh we get yeah to the third
one they finally do all the CT scans and
everything nothing nothing there nothing
there they they start trying to say
she's um
it's like delusion and something else
and all this other stuff
that third one did something because
that night in that bed she was up like
hey
hey
I don't know what's going on and I'm
like
you know it's 11. uh you know you've had
three seizures now you might just need
to you know you need to chill your brain
you don't need to relax again she pops
up hey you know where the remote is and
I was like
you know what I mean it's now two she's
like yeah I need the remote and I gotta
and I gotta do this she starts doing
this [ __ ] with her hands and I'm like
like this isn't uh yeah something right
so I'm I'm recording her because one
it's like she's not gonna believe this
and then two something's not right yeah
so accordingly and like I said I was
like yo mom are you saying am I am I
tripping and she goes no my mom was good
on it she was like I'm glad you remained
calm because you could have freaked her
out even more which could have led to
another seizure whatever but um it gets
to the point to where she has the fourth
seizure and uh she's just flirting out
this random stuff and if you watch the
watch the uh Brain on Fire
same thing to a team man she just like
this is how I know that that girl
definitely like there's no if ands or
buts about it was love because out of
out of that random was Chris needs to
win his fights and I just need my babies
to do it and I was just like you know we
get her uh what actually this time
ambulance comes they finally and the guy
that's looking at her report and he goes
this isn't right why why was she
released after the second one you know
type thing you know what I mean so get
get to the hospital at this point now
it's just a bunch of random testing
plasma treatment all this other Jazz I'm
trying to get ready for a fight Jesus
Christ you know what I mean yeah like
and then I'm trying to get ready for a
fight for how long at this point this is
we would have been this would have been
year 12 this year yeah so this is like
10 10 you know we're like 10 years in uh
so I'm trying to comfort the kids well
I'll get answers myself these doctors
I'm not going to say anything about the
interns but it was a new intern of like
every other day to where I was
explaining it every day yeah I was like
is no one listening no
no you know what I mean so uh ended up
hospital hospital switch hospitals went
to like the best neuro Hospital out
there uh the swelling on their brain had
finally stopped but then like I guess
the white blood cells started attacking
the rest of the body and whatnot so with
that going on 808 her brain a little bit
there's nothing you can do to stop it
there wasn't a damn thing they could do
they try to do the plasma treatment
normally you take out like all the bad
stuff and that's supposed to put in new
white blood cells and everything nothing
nothing like nothing was like they
normally say three normally changes she
ended up having like nine no yeah but
nothing's happened nothing was doing
that like and you're in Camp going
through all this literally like so it
was the doctor I came in usually in this
case it doesn't end well did they know
every other I'll say when we got to
Emory Emory they finally we finally had
like a set three doctors and all of them
were like oh we've seen this uh this is
one uh the Jamaican nurse was cool she
goes she get somebody weed huh this
looked like about weed kiss here and I
was like
yeah
so again I had that glimpse of hope you
know still going into it still uh still
with everything we get into April so now
we're getting closer to the fight
I tell them I was like hey I'm gonna be
out of town for like you know a couple
of days let me know you know I'm I'm
back regardless no you're fine you're
fine go handle your fight
they call me 30 hours before I got to go
out there and fight buddy and tell me
how to make a decision what we just left
a good note like we just left like yeah
they call me 30 hours before the fight
hey so we're calling you know uh about
Alex you know the doctors you know
what's going on no no I don't know
what's going on
he was like hey
you're you're gonna have to make a
decision when you come back you know he
goes pretty much just the machine right
now is keeping her alive and I was like
okay Ashton
you punking me where's the cameras at
how to go from zero to 100 like that
man I don't I think okay so with two of
the first doctors you could tell they
weren't trying to
give me the full information they were
sugar coating oh yeah oh no you know
yeah it happens all the time boom word
for word yeah
this last doctor that came on was like
it's real hey look I'm gonna tell you
right now she's it got to the point to
where like her muscles were
deteriorating and the blood from the
muscles were coming through like her
system it was it was bad it was real bad
you know and then uh fights over kids
graduated and then it was right around
that time uh
they they were like look we we've got to
do the hospice thing you know there's
you know
at this point She's suffering more than
she's what I was she is she conscious of
what's going on or no no like it's it's
she's got these weird Twitches that
she's doing but it's completely
involuntary it's not her like she I
don't want to say it like that but I
think she was technically like gone done
way before that yeah I think um now I'm
thinking April yeah you know what I mean
I could feel it like if something is
right you know what I mean like yeah so
uh they yeah they call with all that we
get back she off the machine like three
four days and where everybody's like
fighting because the one doctor was like
as soon as the machine's off you know
you can go ahead and call it
three four days again there goes that
that Glimpse you're like and then it
finally happened whatever but uh but the
kids actually got to see her alive you
know what I mean before which was which
was cool
um uh especially for Zay because that
was he was a mama's boy oh man he yeah
he my daughter tries to be tough like
her because she was that type that was
uh
I say just
uh she she had the as she would say the
resting [ __ ] face yeah but just she was
tough she was a tough skinny little girl
just like you know didn't take [ __ ] from
no one type thing you know what I mean
uh and my daughter is definitely
portraying that son other side would you
would you I don't know how I came to
America I just tell you I literally I
tell them uh I tell them it's okay to
not be okay because I'm not okay you
know what I mean in that I could see in
his face because he's always looked at
me dad he's tough I was boohooing and he
was you know me and him we have our
moments all the time you know but um but
I was worried that the damn internet had
ruined my daughter like you know I mean
because she had no emotion I was like
you all right are you okay you okay like
you know what I mean but uh but like she
she she finally say it like that but
when she cried she deals with in
different ways yeah you know what I mean
and I'm starting to learn from her you
know I mean how tough she is because
she's got she's got her mom and her 80
like we'll definitely say you know the
20 the athletic side is me yeah
thank God yeah
uh but yeah dude like so with all of
that going on and then seeing them now
and how they are
it throws me off because I was like if
they weren't so tough I know I wouldn't
I'd be in shambles but the fact that
they're just like
yeah and it's just like
all right man as long as y'all are like
that then you know I'll be good too but
you know the second y'all need to break
down please holla at me holla at me you
know what I mean but uh but yeah man you
know not to say it is what it is I can
say from that situation
the growth that happened was crazy like
so like what I was trying to get into
really from that so this last camp three
days before I fly out I totaled my car
like driving a deer it had to be the
biggest deer I've seen in my life thing
ever yeah it might have been this big
total of the complete cars like man like
it was it was air bags we're talking uh
I didn't even know they had they have
like feet airbags now did you know that
no I didn't know that it was a Tesla
they're paying you too much right now
you ready you ready
a mirage a Mitsubishi Mirage
look like Wreck-It Ralph in that [ __ ]
thing
they had uh the airbags in the feet it
had the airbags at the feet
that's what messed me up was the airbag
those things sold the the deer I see the
deer I see the deer I'm like
he's not gonna go he's not gonna go I
know he's not gonna go he's not that
stupid driving
I see the two baby deer the two baby
deers say
now it's done my car's coming let me
turn around this deer said [ __ ] it
yeah and you just whack boom hit him I'm
going at least 55. like uh boom hit him
the troubles when they go into the
windshield dude that's what I was I was
waiting on the glass
first did he go over the top I hit I
think I got a picture of it oh [ __ ] I
hit the uh the side of like or he hit
the side of my car excuse me because I
was going straight you decided to jump
out right you want to be the dumb ass in
the end is life but um but yeah
before the last fight and I of course I
called management and whatnot and they
were like are you okay do we need to I
was like first off what you're not gonna
do is pull this I said you realize what
I went through last camp this is a joke
this is a Mitsubishi Mirage
to what I went through that last Camp so
like three days
the airbags the the the totaling of the
car was completely fine it was the
airbags are made like carpet oh my God
yeah like that and then destroyed your
bag and their backs come out like that
weird like
it was the smell yeah the powder
this can't be healthy yeah yeah I'm
alive but geez
no no there's nothing I know I messed up
uh this like this was hurt yeah this was
bad because I guess I did this or
something and then I had the uh the
Nutty Burn yeah the seat belt burn or
whatever but other than that God you've
been through so you couldn't tell me no
like then that was the thing that wasn't
gonna stop me from like if I made it
through that last one yeah they ain't no
way in hell or deer no throw a bear on
me next you know yeah type thing but uh
I just the thing that is uh I think
special about you is like dealing with
all that with your fiance passed away
the mother of your kids and I I mean I
you know even though it was a it's not
that long ago Dude so if that happened
to me you know I'm I don't I wouldn't be
able to do my job there's no way man it
would definitely steal my light you know
what I'm saying like I'd be a dark
person was tough you're the most
outgoing friendly happy person I know
man it's part of that I've always looked
at
trials and tribulations different than
than than most you know like
you sit there and dwell on it it will
literally consume you it will literally
consume you you know um
of course with something like that you
have to take the time to stop and sit
back I
fortunate enough I got a good group
around me man like that's everything
dude like also for you too though the
example you set for those kids so if you
let that stop in your tracks those kids
are like okay we're stopping too then
exactly you know what I mean so between
between the eyes watching me and then my
little tribe man like you got a good
scrub yeah man like um my homeboys like
we've been friends 30 years now you know
him his wife actually handles my uh
emails and stuff yeah you know what I
mean so the ones I can't really get to
show yeah she'll take care of it and
went not but uh between them
my brother my mom my dad like and then
and then the kids the kids honestly
they've been the strongest or the my
biggest rock like to lean on like that's
insane here that's what throws me off
and I don't ever want them to feel like
they have to do that but I like um I
don't ever hey I'm sad today guys I need
to talk yeah you know what I mean like
in that I could get the wrong ice cream
as weeks
I'll forget that Zay that's uh that's my
son I forget that he's he's seven we we
have like we have adult conversation
we're starting like fights and stuff
yeah so if he throws it over here and
it's just like yeah
it's a Pokemon on or something you know
give me some special people man that's
what that's what's gonna happen that's
super special dude I'm I'm hoping like
I'm with everything that's going on I
feel like I'm doing something right you
know what I mean with them you know what
I mean so I'm [ __ ] telling you man
you're special [ __ ] dude man yeah
yeah
don't cry Wanna Stop it
let's move on to fighting so with
fighting
um obviously for you you know you come
out now you did the damn thing
everybody's you know a fan of you now
but you've been putting in all this work
to you like obviously there's the
personality there in your athletic guy
like what do you see like in your future
you know what I'm saying like you like
are you looking at like all right by
next you're going to be running to the
top 15 top 10 top five then I want to go
for the big boy you know like the Jon
Jones and the Francis and the Cerro gons
the title of asses and the Derrick
Lewis's like you and Derek Lewis First
Team all personality who's the biggest
personality in the [ __ ] us you know
what I'm saying and Derek Lewis was
great I'll get your answer to this Derek
Lewis and I uh used to do some stuff
together back in the day that's about
fighting he's like to be honest man he's
like you know he's like fighting's not
like my heart he's like but he's like
you know it's good money man I hit hard
and he's like but to be honest he's like
the reason I want to lose because he has
like I think six kids he's like my kids
just be making fun of me man he's like I
get home like oh that's why you got
nothing he's like so he's like I don't
care about the internet
you take the trash out yeah so he's like
bro I just want to win so my kids don't
roast me
but for you it's uh how do you see it
coming for us because you have all this
hype on you right now everyone loves you
right you're kind of The Golden Boy the
heavyweight difference right
it's weird to um
to sit back and think I can say this is
this is gonna sound really irresponsible
in the moment I've been in the moment
kind of guy like that's your biggest
skill set like yeah like it's
and I can thrive in those weird
last minute type you know I mean like so
to to look too far ahead I've done that
before and I've I've tripped myself up
I've done that you know secret I did
that yeah like like trying to
okay I know that's there but I'm not
seeing what's right here you know what I
mean I see it open you know so here's a
problem exactly you don't take care of
this this ain't happening and if you
overlook this this dude professional
fighter you give me some trouble telling
you that's the name of my career brother
it's it's always been uh I try to
balance it out like I never try to I
never try to pursue anything yeah but I
never I never try to over like okay
a lot of these guys get into UFC I'm
going to be a champion but next
damn we got to cry yeah we got a green
over here like this
second
the first one yeah just called out Jon
Jones this is insane uh live your dreams
but understand that reality is gonna be
there you know what I mean you know I
think you got a super power mama you
have a superpower with I I don't think
I've ever interviewed a fighter even
when I was fighting and my teammates I
don't think I've ever met someone who's
like grounded like you and literally
it's just like you're just focused on
right now and then getting through
tomorrow and the next day and I think
that's also helped you with the your
your fiance passed away and helps you be
such a good dad you got a [ __ ] super
power my man and you're just getting
started that's that and I know you have
a ton of fights and I you know we've had
a ton of people on here right and then
when I'm around you I'm like oh this
dude's [ __ ] special man I'm telling
you I've interviewed a ton of [ __ ]
people whether it's Comics Fighters
business whatever it is you got
something man you got something dude but
yeah like literally with her with her
passion like that that whole cliche
saying life is too short yes like you
know what I mean like so that that's my
whole thing is one percent better every
day I don't care if you tied your shoes
faster than you tied them yesterday as
long as you did that you know one person
something better than what you were you
know what I mean and that's that's
always been my mindset is like uh I
think I was explaining it earlier like
you you everybody falls in that rut
we're all human at the end of the day
we're gonna fall into that right and I I
fall into it but what I have again is
that core that group the fans for real
now at this point I'll open up my phone
and I'll read those messages I'll read
the messages yo I didn't want to get up
today you made me smile now I'm at the
gym I'm like oh man the night uh after
Jake Collier dude messaged me hey man I
don't know how you do it I just lost my
wife two weeks ago
um he's like I was glad I got to see
your fight I just want to know how
you're this strong yeah I said I'm not
really to be honest with you I said it's
more or less yeah like yeah like like I
I grasp things I understand a lot like
my my grandpa he was one the he kind of
tried to instill it in me young that hey
we're here on Earth you can either be
great and do whatever you can be bad you
know there's there's choices and
consequences to everything that we do
but you also have to understand we're
not here for forever yeah what are you
gonna do while you're here type thing
you know and it's just like
my thing is I want to be impactful I
want to be I want to I want to know that
I I touched you know somebody
you're doing it good good man now my
DM's a little different than you were
like man I was having a good day I saw
your face I'm like all right well I'm
not gonna read through this that's the
difference
mine is fire yeah not a good one I've
gotten those I've gotten a couple lines
that's when you know you're doing
something right exactly as long as I get
haters yeah and you know like we were
just talking about it uh but that was
one thing too that I was I was ending up
doing I've got 400 we love you I love
you Chris this is great I've got one oh
you fat piece of [ __ ] and you're like
that's the one you're focused
I said how dare you call me
yeah somebody else that's what I used to
think you fat [ __ ] I'm like Who you
calling thick and he's like dude it's
literally your brand you [ __ ] idiot
all right have a good day man he's got a
point yeah
well dude uh man I can't wait for your
next fight I can't wait man again I've
done a lot of these shows this might be
my favorite one man you're a special
[ __ ] dude man you're gonna go yeah
man yeah not only do you have a lot to
do in the UFC to try and become Champion
there but whatever you want to do
outside the UFC listen I'm in this
entertainment public you could [ __ ]
do this you probably take my job you
understand what the [ __ ] you want to do
probably take my job so let's not retire
yet I got you I got kids too
man all right don't don't jump on over
the entertainment yeah man I'm just
getting my beat wet bro but uh yeah
before you go man we always give guys
kicks and uh we got to give you a
special pair of kicks I'm a sneaker head
through man yeah I'm a super sneaker
head now you got some dope jokes on
there yeah got the got the ones with the
with the get the ones now yeah get once
you show them though those are filthy
those are dope now these you gotta put
the white laces in yeah
you're dope no like I just cussed the
dude out at the store because it didn't
have any blue like yes yes sir what
yo yes sir I'm wearing these today
special shoe for a special guy man
you're an OG and he's got the weight
laces yeah these are filled yeah I got a
[ __ ] walking yeah because yeah give them
a little oh
[Laughter]
filthy with the white laces yeah that's
what I would do but my man's special
shoe for a special dude and uh I I just
I can't think enough for coming on
yep you're the best brother appreciate
it again man thank you sometimes you've
got the Rhythm I don't though I
sometimes I do I've seen you I've seen
you I've seen little do you know I used
to I used to I used to I used to watch
you I know about your lacrosse days oh
[ __ ] yeah oh yeah look now okay all
right brother your brother's name is Jay
yeah he's gonna love this you're Jay's
favorite fighter now yeah he's my
manager on the road see like what's up
big Jay
yeah man no like like because like I was
saying like when when you beat uh uh
Marcus Jones actually that whole tough
10. like that that one you were you were
one of the football player Fighters that
I could deal with what was that Abe was
it hey Wagner yeah yeah I was like
watching on the show you and Metrion uh
I loved I loved but yeah I was just like
you're giving us football players yeah
because it was yeah it was it was Abe
Metrion and then Marcus Jones yeah Mitch
your own actually like I played the well
they've been playing the NFL I had a
cappuccino with the Buffalo Bills
Mitchell played like who was like on the
team like played in games for like three
or four years and then March Jones like
yeah
he tackled Barry Sanders yeah he was a
first round draft Tampa like he couldn't
go anywhere type thing man like he he
was a Marcus Jones was that guy legit
and like a really nice guy hands down
man like hopefully he's cool with me
I've never talked [ __ ] about him you
know it was all business man and he also
broke my nose he would still love you
like again like training with guys like
that seeing how he had everything you
know I mean NFL he's such everything you
can think of and then he was just so
humble yes that's those are the guys
that I came into the game with like
that's all I could see like again the
kimballs yes coming to the gym he knows
what he didn't know and he was more than
less than like he was willing to to open
up and be like I don't know this help me
yeah and they're all good people yeah
dude yeah Marcus Kimbo they're all just
really good people all good dudes man
and you're you're following those
footsteps on man so wish you the best
they call you Beast Boy that's it who
came with that game for Relief Beast Boy
okay because when I think of Beast Boy I
think of uh Teen Titans team
initially Beast Boy was I was when I was
younger I could mimic animals run like
them jump from trees uh we had this
thing where I I could seal a waddle into
it like you named the animal I could
either mimic it or or like make the
sound I feel like that crush on Tick
Tock right now
hey look man we working in the lab yeah
uh but now you take Beast Boy that
moniker you put it in the cage Beast Boy
is a creature that can turn into
different animals yeah in that cage
you've got to be able to turn into
different animals if I'm standing gotta
be a bear if I'm on the ground I got to
be a snake you know what I mean so it
just kind of fit at that point you know
I mean at that at that form and then
when I was overseas they love cute
cuddly big whatever so that's where the
Huggy Bear had come from yeah she's just
a little weird right wow they're very
very Hands-On very uh anybody offer to
buy your underwear yet not yet socks
okay Beast Boy what that what the
Mondays do y'all what I said I wouldn't
do that to you yeah that only gonna get
pink eye you're gonna miss me it's not
gonna be fun man it's just PV stands in
front anyway uh I love the LinkedIn
Beast Boy dude again you're crushing one
of my favorite episodes of all time man
I appreciate we'll have you on again
you're the best brother good luck take
care of those kiddos tell them I said
what's up that's it Chris Barnett aka
the Beast Boy if you're into thick boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding